jean michel maire vous êtes le savez que
vous êtes le chroniqueur préféré de
valérie je l'ignoré mais j'en suis ravi
que je sais qu'elle est célibataire
battant et en plus elle a dit qu'elle
aimerait bien danser avec vous dans le
respect des eft barrière alors est-ce
qu'on se fait cette danse les cherry ou
est ce qu'on dit non alors je vous le
dis avec cédric et aval mais vous avez
intérêt à faire une autre banque que
d'habitude j'en peux plus de voir on est
armés de deux armes et alors mais on
dirait que même les madones soit tu
connais bien ma loge et jolie c'est
parti
mais le regard
la sécu il échoue à lait maternel est
ringard 2007 du mât les bas les rimes a
tiré ce que c'est pas ton style de mec
jean-michel oui où je pense non un peu
comme moi des maximes maxime maxime ça
va mais ça veut dire quoi ça va ces
plaisanteries quoi maxime et je sais
bien excuser moi est ce que je peux vous
poser une question et c'est normal sous
ses pas vu pendant deux mois je peux
déjà plus vous plairait pour des sacs et
aux téléspectateurs varie entre maxime
et julie déjà maxime c'est vrai tu
pourras avoir une aventure avec maxime
c'est bon on a compris
nous avons néanmoins collard méchant
mais quand je t'ai d'une aventure c'est
voilà une aventure amoureuse
peut-être c'est à dire vivre une
histoire avec maxime faut il faut
discuter d'accord et maxime c'est austin
valérie labelle est très joli mais
malheureusement je suis en couple donc
ils avaient romer merci valérie aller
battre eddie fico tout cas et je suis
très heureux un très beau public ce soir
un merci en tout cas précis en syrie
pour le cadeau les médias son public
c'est un des meilleurs danseurs de
france